joining me now is nigel farage former uk
brexit party leader
nigel um look hurling unsubstantiated
claims of racism
on national tv at your royal in-laws and
then
getting your critics canceled is this
not the
ultimate privilege oh yes it certainly
is and uh you know
megan married into the royal family um i
think it was clear from day one
what her intentions were it was very
interesting at that wedding three years
ago which fox news covered
so well oprah winfrey was a guest at the
wedding
despite the fact meghan markle had only
met her once before so i think their
intentions were clear
to accuse the royal family to accuse the
queen effectively
who next year will have reigned for 70
years but not just over the uk
she's the head of the commonwealth over
50 countries
2.3 billion people the vast majority of
whom
are asian or black our royal family has
done a huge amount
people of color all over the world that
was unsubstantiated
much else of what she said was simply
untrue
her grandson they wouldn't give poor
little archie
a princeton but a great grandchild of
the monarch
does not get one of those titles it was
a false claim
prince harry said my father cut me off
financially
but only when they'd left the uk
given up their royal juices and gone to
the west coast so the whole thing
the whole thing was a fabrication it was
from meghan markle
an acting performance to emote to
plead with people that she had victim
status
and also of course to say that she
suffered badly
from mental health problems and had
thought
perhaps about taking her own life all i
can say is that young woman
the other night didn't appear to me to
have any mental health problems
but it is shocking that if you attack
somebody
who claims they've got a mental health
problem you're suddenly
the villain and i don't underplay the
importance of mental health
but people using it as an excuse
to mention the bottom line yeah the
bottom line nigel i mean to call you but
you can't claim racism
generally not name anybody
and then just kind of go like this and
say thanks oprah for the interview
you just can't you cannot do that well
she did it and she got away with it
because she's in the elite club they
they cover for each other
they protect one another and then they
they sign lucrative deals and then
we're supposed to you know cry all the
way to the bank for them uh it's just
ridiculous and it's just it's demeaning
to true
discrimination and hardship of all these
people suffering around the world and
here in the united states
i just it doesn't it doesn't sit well i
think with a lot of folks who
want to want them to have great lives
and be happy it doesn't sit well with
folks i don't think but
you're not going to be surprised nigel
that hillary clinton weighed in on the
big markle drama the british tabloids
their cruelty in going after megan
uh was just outrageous this is
2021 uh and she wanted to live her life
it was heartbreaking to see the two of
them sitting there
having to describe um
how difficult it was to be accepted
nigel considering how the british press
treats you
you should we expect to see you sitting
down with oprah sometime
soon you'll be given the same treatment
right how did you feel nigel when they
attacked you how did you
feel when they called you oh i've been
called all the names under the sun but
then
you know i challenged the establishment
megan arrived in the uk
had a fairytale wedding the country took
her to her heart
the press were gushing with praise about
her
i'll tell you when the criticism started
it started
when she and harry started lecturing us
on carbon emissions
and climate change yet flying around the
world in private jet
and frankly and you know what the
british press are like the printed press
everybody in public life gets a tough
time in the uk
nobody is tough as me but everyone gets
a tough time
and again hillary clinton saying all she
wanted to do
was live her life no she married into
the royal family she married into what
we call the firm
she married into a job she knew what she
was getting into nigel
and she should have googled how to
curtsy
or at least learn that in acting school
all right nigel thanks so much